students from Stoneman Douglas high
visited members of Congress yesterday
they met with a number three House
Republican majority whip Steve Scalise
of Louisiana he was nearly killed in a
shooting at a congressional baseball
practice last June Scalise made it
through seven surgeries and returned to
work just three months later he's with
us now from the Capitol congressman good
morning thank you so much for joining us
good morning Gail and John and hey Nora
how are you I'm well thank you
I know what you met with some of these
survivors what kind of changes did they
ask for members of Congress to make we
talked about policy but really we talked
a lot about shared experience and
obviously it got very emotional you know
some of the things that they've been
through or similar to some of the things
that I've been through and you know this
could be a tough time for them it
already is you know but this doesn't go
away it's something that I know me and
the other members of the Congressional
baseball team still talk a lot about
what we went through and I'm sure they
as students are going to continue
talking about what they went through but
we did talk again about some policy but
mostly just about where we are right now
I want to ask you about some of those
specifics of policy because some of the
survivors have talked about raising the
age limit for those to be able to
purchase an assault rifle the president
has indicated he might support that
raising the age to 21 would you support
that well right now I think if you look
the laws are varied in every state also
has the ability to change their law but
there are a number of things that are
being looked at right now that's not one
of the ones that's being talked about as
much as basically as closing loopholes
we have a lot of mental health issues we
have some breakdowns at the federal and
local level and law enforcement clearly
a lot of us have serious questions about
the FBI and why this wasn't stopped in
the first place when they had this kid
handed to him on a silver platter months
ago congressman in talking to some of my
relatives who have ar-15s they hear this
debate taking place and they think it's
an assault on their freedoms and that
they are being lumped in with people who
clearly shouldn't have access to weapons
do you hear that same argument from your
constituents I do hear that from
constituents and and look millions of
people have
weapons like the ar-15 and use them to
defend themselves they have it for self
defense which is the tenets of the
Second Amendment and so that's one of
the things that you've got a balance
when you're looking at change in laws
you've got to recognize number one in
cases like this shooting and so many
others multiple laws were already broken
but worse than that big signs were
missed in many cases by government
itself and the fact that government
missed so many of the signs and didn't
do the things that they should have done
to protect people is one of the reasons
that people feel they should have a need
to protect themselves and their family
given what you've said and people's
feeling about personal freedom the
request from some of the students in
parkland and and other places that there
be some limitations any limitations of
any kind on the ar-15 that's just not
going to happen is it you know again
that's not one of the big discussions
here closing problems with the loopholes
loopholes especially with the instant
background check system we passed a bill
in the house called fix Nick's which a
lot of people are rallying around that
closes a lot of those loopholes with the
instant background check system that's a
bill that passed the house it was tied
to concealed carry reciprocity something
that's been proven to actually increase
safety and so that's one of the things
that we sent over the Senate the
Senate's looking at a different version
of that bill they haven't passed
anything yet on their side but that is a
bill that has passed the house it's
pretty clear that law enforcement missed
some very important clues and signals
they had lots of warnings it seems but
if someone who has been through a
shooting do you still support ar-15s
being on the street well again you could
talk about any one weapon and if you ban
that weapon does that mean that nothing
else is gonna happen I think if you look
I was fortunate in my case that I had
law enforcement there on the scene who
acted accordingly and took down the
shooter I wish that would have happened
at the school where clearly there was at
least one law enforcement officer on the
scene who hit instead of confronting the
shooter maybe there were more I think
that needs to come out and when was that
known
I think those are the kind of things
that we want to know when we say before
people go changing laws to take away the
rights of law-abiding citizens let's get
the fact and see if other people didn't
do their job and enforcing existing law
that's what anger so many people yeah
because the existing laws are broken and
then people want to change other laws
that infringe on law-abiding citizens
you talked about an emotional meeting
that you had with the students and I'm
sure it was that there was a very
interesting article in The New York
Sunday Times with a reporter who said by
day these students are activists who are
out there talking about gun control but
at night they are still healing very
scared kids what advice did you give to
them or what did you what can you say to
them as someone who's been through this
on how to heal what I shared with them
is obviously what they're doing up here
is very important and I think it's it's
great that they are engaging in the
political process but when they go back
home they're gonna be high school
students again and at some point they're
gonna be getting on with their daily
lives and this is gonna still be
lingering with them that the problems
that they're gonna be facing they ought
to be talking amongst themselves I'm
sure there'll be school appointed
counselors but the fact that these all
these students all went through this
together they should continue talking to
each other
don't go hide in the corner and kind of
repress those feelings because months
later it could become a bigger issue
talk through that experience that's what
we do up here and it's helped all of us
on the baseball team get through this
they ought to be doing the same thing
all right congressman Scalise it's
really good to see you sir couldn't see
you thank you for joining us